I was friends with Larry right we had
worked on another project together
called my trip to al-qaeda which is a
one-man play that he had done based on
his reporting of a looming tower I read
Larry's book and it was really the idea
of the prison of belief that made me
interested in taking it on because I
felt it was worth the agony that I knew
was going to come because it was about
Scientology but it was also about much
more and in an era in which we live in
which we see you know groups like Isis
and others in which you know this idea
of blind faith propels you to do the
most appalling things the idea of the
prison of belief is is a really
important one and so by telling this
story we're telling Scientology story
which is an important of it in and of
itself but it also gets at a deeper
psychological issue i think the the
background on l ron hubbard i think a
lot of us know a little about Hubbard
and a couple years ago when the mass for
the paul thomas anderson film came out a
lot of stuff came out as well um one of
the things I love is that the the film
you really you don't cast a you just let
him sort of hang himself with his own
with his own creativity his own
fabrications um but going into the
background on that in in telling Hubbard
story of that I think that it comes off
as a little bit like you know with just
a little twist of fate he could have
been a junior our Tolkien as something
else like he could have been a sort of
successful creative slight madman as he
calls himself but I mean he was a
novelist you know he was a storyteller
and actually if you think about it you
know a lot of there's another person you
know I've been doing a film about for a
number of years Steve Jobs who was also
a storyteller and I think that was his
great talent you know storytellers
capture our imaginations in ways and I
think it was that aspect of it that that
that mate Robert I think so powerful and
so dangerous but that's who he was at
heart you know he couldn't he knew the
power of his own imagination and
and it kept coming back you know he
started Scientology well first Dianetics
and Scientology as a way to make money
you know so that you wouldn't get taxed
but by the end he's got old Sarge
they're hooking up the e meter to the
Tesla coil trying to blow body fate ins
out of him you know at the expense of
his life ok well that's a that's that's
true belief america is the country where
you always believe on a moment's notice
you can reinvent yourself and i also
think that that's one of the things that
appealed to him about the movie industry
you know one of the things that struck
me you know i remember as a young
trailer cutter and then assistant editor
you know i remember the head of the
studio is working at you know would
always take time to you know in the
middle of a mix to listen to the pitch
of the guy who opened the gate for the
lot because he had a new script idea and
I and that was a very Hollywood idea
which was both weird and pretentious but
also actually kind of wonderful the idea
that you know he could be he could have
a great idea and then everything would
be fine so there's something wonderful
about that even as it's you know 99
times out of a hundred a kind of
crushing burden right well let's admit
that that in the 70s everything was up
for grabs and so the idea that there was
a religion that didn't have god that was
appealing and it was called Scientology
so there was something about science to
do and and by the way when you first put
your hands on those cans and you and you
talk to a skilled auditor and a lot of
the auditors in Scientology including
Marty Rathbun it was in the film were
skilled at being extraordinarily
empathetic and inculcating in people a
sense of belief in themselves so that
that suddenly wow I felt feel really
good and it's no accident that
Scientology took really took root in
Hollywood in particular not only because
it was good for them
have these pitchmen but also actors in
particular I think you know it's a
profession in which you have to be
vulnerable because otherwise you can't
get into other people's characters and
so it's it's in a way the the perfect
time and the perfect place part of
Scientology think is that once people
say you've got to speak out against
these abuses and then Tom Cruise calls
David Miscavige Miscavige are there any
abuses absolutely not Tom these are
haters these are apostates these are
bigots and then it's like you can feel
good by opposing them and it gives you a
sense of moral power so I fear that's
what's happening and yet we know from
the spankee story that Travolta reached
out to her and said how are you allowing
the church to do what they're doing to
you but somewhere along the line either
because of what was in the PC folders or
because of the help that they gave him
whatever he wouldn't really go there he
wouldn't really confront the idea that
this place which was giving him help and
and and maybe comfort that they were
committing abuses and so they turn a
blind eye it's at cognitive dissonance
and so the question is whether or not
all of us and those in the industry who
are close to people like cruising
Travolta will put enough pressure on
them not that it renounce their beliefs
but to at least investigators speak out
about the abuses because I that's the
other thing about this you know I tried
to make the film in a way so that much
like film I made before this maiya
Maxima culpa about the Catholic Church
and the sex abuse crisis is not about
belief it's about abuse it's how the
institutions manipulate that belief to
commit the most appalling abuses in
order to enforce the institution because
this whole process of disconnection
which is in the film so elegant immuno
so so movingly spoken about by so many
people that's a device
meant to keep membership and keep the
money flowing you know that what is it
what does that have to do with auditing
or feeling better about yourself for
many people they feel like for them to
admit that Scientology has led them
astray means that they have to admit
that their whole life has been a lie I
think the the folk that they get on the
best and Marty in recent days has been a
minister to people in terms of and even
at a screening we had in Texas a few
nights ago was very good at that almost
a laying on of hands the idea that it's
not you haven't wasted your life it's
part of a journey that you've taken
that's gotten you to this moment if you
can see it that way then people tend to
come out better but but it it's very
difficult for people to leave because to
recognize oh my god everything that I
believed it was wrong it's like that
moment in the bridge on the river kwai
when Alec Guinness you know suddenly
looks up and realizes oh my god you know
we've been helping the Japanese army and
they were about to send a and and and
the commandos are on our side and we're
trying to shoot them you know what is
going on it's a great analogy that's
absolutely so apt the other thing is
mike rinder it feels to me so alone he
feels in these in these interviews I
mean this is a guy who was in it we were
just talking from when he was a kid was
in the Sea Org at 16 kind of comes out
like a newborn in some ways a complete
you know he's been in it for so many
years and I can't imagine anybody who
wouldn't want him by the way as a
spokesman he's so fun to listen to and
so engaging and so there but he kind of
comes out and it's in a way it's like
he's had his life spent on these skills
in in you know in service of something
so nefarious you can see him I mean
that's the most brutal you know when
Mike is Mike had to sit in the audience
at Sundance and be confronted with him
singing with an almost messianic gaze
you know we stand tall not to mention
you know when he's interviewed by John
Hockenberry saying yeah I think anybody
who disagrees with this is a criminal
and the interview when he goes to the
BBC when it we see my BBC nan Sweeney he
was
he was in the hole and they brought him
out at about those moments right to to
defend Miscavige and and everything and
then they bring him back but those those
moments when you're seeing him shouting
at John Sweeney are Logan he's free for
a few and it was that you know everybody
wonders how does it snap how do you snap
out of it and I think was that whiplash
like here he is being beaten by David
Miscavige in the hole and he's sent to
London to defend the church and talk
about how that's utter rubbish and how
dare you attack this magnificent
institution and frankly you know the
church recently has put out a lot of
online documentaries about me and
everybody else in the film online and
you can see that kind of fervent belief
in the people being interviewed for
those things it's a little bit scary